a very powerful
insight transpired for me today
a realization in which the doors of
perception were
cleansed i experienced a kind of
dissolving
of patterns of behavior
that i'm normally embedded or nested
in i became aware in an instant through
a kind of aesthetic detachment
of the game loops that most people
are running people are kind of running
on a script they're going through the
motions right
there's a kind of autopilot a kind of
routine
right think of it again as a game loop
we're all game
characters and game designers understand
this
like no one else you design a game
character and you create these game
loops of behavior the human game loop
of 21st century quotidian normal might
be described
by saying you wake up you brush your
teeth you drink coffee
you make a poop you go to work you pay
the bills
you drink some food you sleep again
you're kind of running on a game
loop everyone's on autopilot and what
happens
is the world shines with effervescence
the world is radiating with
miraculousness and most of us are half
asleep
running on a game loop we're game
characters unable to wake up but a
moment
of awakening a moment in which we wake
from our stupor
is a moment in which the world assumes
the proportions
of a miracle this is when time
becomes liquid this is when we move
from chronopression right from
kronos to kairos the liberation
of mythopoetic reality the liberation
of the archetypal realm the liberation
of plato's realm of ideals finally
a space in which the world assumes the
proportions
of a miracle the world glistens and
radiates with effervescence the world
beams your eyeballs with starlight right
with its sheer miraculousness and in
these
moments when you dissolve your game loop
you become like a child knowing the
world
for the first time you attain a sense of
first sight
unencumbered by knowingness you attain a
virginal
noticing of the sensate world and like
aldous huxley wrote
in the doors of perception you're like
adam
from adam and eve in the sense that
you're no longer
looking at the world as a set of unusual
arrangements but instead
you are seeing what adam had seen on the
morning
of his creation the miracle moment
by moment of naked existence